so my name is Jeremy Mihalik I'm an
associate professor of mechanical
engineering and engineering and public
policy and I run the vehicle
electrification group at Carnegie Mellon
I got my doctorate degree from the
University of Michigan and I've been
looking at cars for a long time but it
was really at Carnegie Mellon that I
became interested in the issue of
converting our vehicle fleet to electric
sources of energy we look at large
systems issues of electric vehicles
including consumer adoption the design
of vehicle and battery systems
infrastructure and the larger economic
environmental and policy implications of
vehicle electrification we've had a
couple of studies that suggest that our
federal and state policies are targeting
the wrong electric vehicles now the
current policies favor vehicles with
large battery packs such as battery only
electric vehicles but it turns out if
you look at the full lifecycle plug-in
hybrid electric vehicles with small
battery packs that drive short distances
on electricity and switch to gasoline
for longer trips are actually better for
the environment these vehicles offer
more reductions in air emissions they
save more gasoline per dollar spent they
avoid being dependent on the
construction of a massive network of
charging infrastructure and they're more
likely to be adopted at mainstream
levels in the near term which can help
create a market for automotive batteries
that will drive down costs and make
larger packs more competitive in the
future vehicle electrification is one of
these cases where attempting to leapfrog
directly into a new paradigm in a single
step may be counterproductive if we
instead take a path through intermediate
technology of hybrid vehicles we can get
more near term benefits for the
environment and national security at
lower costs with a lower risk of
backlash from over-promising and
under-delivering while still keeping our
options open in case of competing
technology like fuel cells or natural
gas vehicles causes us to rethink the
future of personal transportation